Ask yourself a simple question: is the world
around you real?
It seems like the answer should be pretty
obvious, of course the world as you know it
is real, how else would you be able to interact
with it?
Perhaps a better question would be this: how
much do you trust that the world you know
is real?
How much do you believe that reality, as you
experience it, is constant and cannot be changed
by external forces?
Now imagine, if you can, an entity to which
the very fabric of reality is like clay, able
to be shaped and moulded at will.
Then imagine that this entity, this malicious,
twisted, and unknowable horror, has taken
a special interest in you.
If you can picture such a scenario, then you
may as well be standing in the shoes of James
Talloran, a Foundation Researcher assigned
to SCP-3999.
Talloran could only have imagined what the
Foundation kept contained in an airtight cell
all the way at the bottom of a kilometer-long
shaft; and never expected that it was where
his lifeless body would be found.
Despite having the entity contained, The Foundation’s
only knowledge of SCP-3999 came from a text
document discovered on Talloran’s phone
after his demise.
Even their own records indicated no such creature
ever existed.
Why?
What could possibly shape reality in such
a way that it could hide its own existence
from the Foundation and where was it now?
The document on Talloran’s phone yielded
some evidence, seeming to be a long, rambling
and confused account of some sort of battle
between a reality-shaping entity and the ill-fated
researcher sent to examine it.
Unlike many of the Foundation’s documents,
the entry for SCP-3999 is riddled with contradictions
and strikethroughs, a confusing mess of information
that makes piecing together the mystery of
Talloran’s fate all the more difficult.
Beneath the strange formatting and uncertainty
surrounding SCP-3999, lies a tale of one man’s
torture for the amusement of an impossibly
powerful, and eternally sadistic creature.
Based on the information available, it appears
that SCP-3999 was fixated on Talloran.
Upon his arrival to the entity’s cell, the
researcher had no idea how long he would spend
in the company of SCP-3999, or that he would
never emerge alive.
Many SCPs contained by the Foundation require
their own, specially made prisons in order
to hold them, and maintain the safety of Foundation
staff as well as the outside world.
But imagine if an SCP could turn the tables,
bending the world around a single member of
the Foundation, using all of reality as their
own personalized torture chamber.
The list of horrors endured by Talloran is
both exhaustive and incomplete, given the
length of time he spent with the creature.
Shortly after James Talloran was assigned
to Site 118, where SCP-3999 was contained,
the entity was somehow able to breach containment,
and began to twist the world around it in
the name of a singular, cruel objective: the
torture of James Talloran.
The creature, while having no physical description,
possessed the capability to cause either a
CK-Class reality-restructuring event or a
ZK-Class end-of-reality event.
SCP-3999 was somehow able to both destroy
reality itself, while simultaneously rebuilding
it around its prisoner, Researcher Talloran.
Every creature, person and machination that
SCP-3999 created was done so with the express
intention of making Talloran suffer horribly,
over the course of millions of years, according
to the researcher’s own writings.
The exact details of how SCP-3999 tortured
Talloran are littered throughout the document
he was found with, but it is apparent that
the entity was able to use its reality-altering
abilities to continually revive the man after
killing him as a way to prolong his pain.
SCP-3999 seemed to be able to use its powers
however it pleased, but focused all its attention
and actions on causing misery for one man.
It simply enjoyed inflicting suffering.
One of the examples of the atrocities James
Talloran suffered at the mercy of a cold,
remorseless creature, was witnessing the deaths
of others.
Although they were constructed and controlled
by SCP-3999, Talloran saw trained Foundation
security personnel drag three people into
the cell.
He recognized them instantly as his own family.
Talloran was made to watch as his mother,
father and sister were executed with a single
gunshot to the head by members of the same
organization that he was a part of.
All of Talloran’s professional colleagues
were also killed in front of him, followed
by anyone and everyone that had ever come
into contact with James Talloran – including
the O5 Council.
He was made to watch as they were systematically
murdered one by one, all for the enjoyment
of SCP-3999.
At some point during the creature’s torture
of Talloran, there appears to have been some
attempt to contain SCP-3999 within another
SCP.
SCP-2432, a room within a hotel now owned
by the Foundation that appears to compel its
guests to write exaggerated positive reviews
after staying there.
When introduced to SCP-2432, SCP-3999’s
ability to alter reality seemed to have the
effect of creating a dimensional anomaly within
the hotel.
A crawl space opened up in SCP-2432, leading
to an almost-identical room.
The front door of this new room, designated
SCP-2432-1, led to an alternate dimension
that resembled the hotel housing SCP-2432.
The rooms of this new version of the SCP-2432
hotel were a seemingly infinite, endless loop
of rooms.
This dimension also played host to a number
of strange creatures, as uncovered by Foundation
research teams that ventured there.
Most notably, a creature resembling a male
homo sapien calling itself ‘Researcher Talloran’.
This being was dressed in clothing similar
to Foundation researchers, and appeared nervous
and confused when approached by personnel,
only to be executed when asking to be told
the location of SCP-3999.
Later during SCP-3999’s three-million-year
torture session, James Talloran was interviewed
with another doctor working for the Foundation.
The interviewing doctor had no recollection
of Talloran’s assignment to SCP-3999, and
both James’ involvement with the Foundation
and the very existence of SCP-3999 were expunged
from the Foundation’s database.
As Talloran desperately tried to rationalize
what was happening to him, he told the interviewer:
“I have trouble focusing on things now.
I just feel a lot of unease.
It's like reality has started to feel less…real…if
that makes sense.”
Shortly after, he attempted to ask the doctor
for his name, and for him to identify which
of the Foundation’s sites they were at.
In response, the doctor emitted a strange
noise from his mouth, confusing Talloran.
“That's not a name, you just made a noise
with your mouth,” the researcher replied.
“Why am I thinking of redactions?
How can a word be redacted like that in normal
conversation?”
Following this, the floor beneath James Talloran’s
feet disappeared and he was swallowed by darkness,
as SCP-3999 continued bending reality to make
him suffer.
What followed were multiple failed attempts
from Talloran to either escape from the entity
or nullify its abilities to warp reality.
SCP-3999 had, at a later point, trapped Talloran
in a stage play version of its cell.
As James frantically tried to escape out of
a nearby door, where he hoped to find reality,
he was met with a solid wall.
“I'm trapped in whatever this place is with
this thing, and there's no outside reality
anymore,” he realized.
Researcher Talloran tried to understand the
entity, but SCP-3999 defied description, it
was simply chaos.
In his desperation, Talloran was able to dig
a tiny hole in the floor, through which he
could see a light.
Filled with thoughts of his beloved family,
his colleagues and the rest of the world that
had once existed, he opened the hole wider.
It is unclear what happened after this, but
it is apparent that James Talloran was still
unable to escape SCP-3999.
However, as the situations he found himself
in grew increasingly strange, James Talloran
was able to take greater control of his predicament.
This is evidenced in the Foundation’s document
regarding SCP-3999:
“Researcher Talloran cannot be contained
by this.
Researcher Talloran will fight his way back.
Researcher Talloran will recontain SCP-3999.”
This torture had gone on long enough, and
Researcher James Talloran was determined to
be free of the creature that had taken such
sick pleasure in his pain.
Talloran at one point was able to subdue SCP-3999,
although it is initially unclear how he accomplished
this.
There were several attempts made to contain
the entity, using a recursive joke, a melon,
the graves of American crime novelist Robert
B. Parker or an O5 Council member, and a roach
motel.
It is believed that every single one of these
attempts failed.
Attempting to beat the creature at its own
game, Talloran tried to turn SCP-3999’s
reality-altering powers against it by imagining
the entity as something easier to subdue.
These included several mouldy blankets, a
murderous penguin, and a pillow.
Eventually, Talloran was able to contain SCP-3999
with the aid of forty-eight trained containment
personnel, all of whom were also Researcher
Talloran.
During this time, a conversation between the
two was partially recorded, although any dialogue
from SCP-3999 suffered from data corruption.
Claiming to finally be in charge and in control
of the situation, Talloran interrogated SCP-3999,
berating the creature for keeping him prisoner:
“You can't frighten me anymore.
For the first million years of nonsensical
containment procedures and tortures and dream
logic, it was the worst pain I had ever felt,
but I survived.
For the second million years…it was still
the hardest thing I had ever done, but I survived.
By the third million years, I was growing
numb.”
The researcher tried to ascertain the exact
nature and origin of SCP-3999, but to no avail.
Vowing to fight the entity, Talloran told
it:
“Here's the thing about horror and weirdness:
the more you reveal of it, the less effect
it has.
I am sick of your horror.
I am sick of you.”
Afterwards, he was melted into goo for five
years.
It appears that, shortly after this, Researcher
Talloran managed to understand how to destroy
SCP-3999.
While the entity was immortal and virtually
unstoppable, he realized its weakness: that
it had to bond to another being in order to
survive.
Upon discovering this, Talloran took his own
life, causing all that SCP-3999 had done to
disappear.
After Foundation Researcher James Talloran
committed suicide, reality reverted to its
original state before SCP-3999 had heavily
altered it, his death freeing reality from
the evil entity once and for all.
The Foundation remains unaware of what SCP-3999
was, or indeed is, and one can only guess
as to why the entity subjugated Talloran to
such torture and horror.
What made this powerful reality-bender hold
such a perverse fixation on one man?
Some have likened the creature to a horror
writer, continually subjecting a character
to all manner of nightmares before deciding
to redraft and try something new.
Whatever it was, SCP-3999 carries with it
a warning that reality isn’t always as it
seems.
Check out “SCP – 5000 – The Suit”
and “SCP – 106 – The Old Man” for
more horrifying tales from the SCP Foundation.